- Hello, everybody, I'm Kim Goff-Crews,
Secretary and Vice President
for University Life
and the Senior Officer in charge
of the belonging at Yale Initiative.
This event is the first in a
series of events on anti racism
that is being done in conjunction
with the belonging at Yale Initiative.
This is the university's major initiative
to create a climate of
belonging for all of us,
faculty, students, staff, and alumni.
The series is open to all staff, students,
faculty and alumni.
And on December 2nd,
we'll host our second
speaker, Dr. Ibram X. Kendi,
historian and author of
"How to Be an Antiracist."
Today, over 800 people
registered for this conversation,
and most of our guests are staff,
so a special welcome to you.
Many thanks to Deborah Stanley-McAulay,
who is the Associate Vice
President for employee engagement
and workplace culture,
and of course her team
for their generous support of this event.
Our guest today is Dr. Dolly
Chugh, Social Psychologist,
NYU Stern School of Business
Associate Professor,
and the author of "The
Person You Mean to Be:
How Good People Fight Bias."
In her book, Dr. Chugh
provides practical applications
to evidence based research
that can help us address our own biases
in our personal lives
and in our workplace.
She helps us understand
how we can be better
by practicing vulnerability,
understanding our privilege,
making mistakes, and learning from them
with a growth mindset.
She reminds us that we have
things to learn, all of us.
We're not always the
people who we mean to be
or even think we are.
But most of us are good
people trying to do better.
Dr. Laurie Santos will
facilitate the conversation
and incorporate questions
that have been submitted in advance.
Now she doesn't need an introduction,
but I am gonna say a few words
for the few of you who don't know her.
Dr. Santos is a Yale
Professor of Psychology
and Head of Silliman College
She hosts the very popular
podcast, "The Happiness Lab"
and is the Director of the
Comparative Cognition Laboratory
and the Canine Cognition Center at Yale.
Her course, psychology and the good life
is the most popular course
ever taught at Yale.
Is my pleasure to turn the
program over to Dr. Santos
to introduce Dr. Chugh,
and begin What I know is gonna be
a really informative conversation.
- Thank you so much, Kim,
for that introduction.
And thanks so much for
having me at this first panel
on belonging at Yale.
I'm super thrilled to be part of it.
Kim already gave you a quick introduction
to Dolly Chugh's work,
but since I love her and her work so much,
I couldn't help but kind of
tell you a little bit more
about what she's been up to.
As mentioned, Dolly is
an Associate Professor
at NYU Stern School of Business.
But her work really
focuses on this problem
of what it means to be a good person
and the psychological mechanisms
that make up being a good person.
Her book, "The Person You Mean to Be:
How Good People Fight Bias"
is one of my favorite books out there
and you should definitely check it out.
You should also check out her newsletter,
which is called Dear Good People,
you can sign up
@dollychugh.com/newsletter.
And it is fantastic because
while her book is a whole host of insights
and her book length
worth of wonderful tips
for how you can kind of
fight by us all the time,
her newsletter will give
you one actionable tip
every single time you receive it,
and it's a fantastic
way to kind of keep up
with your anti racism efforts.
But it's also worth noting just
how important Dolly has been
in this fight so far,
and just how much of an impact she's had.
As with most people,
Dolly has had an amazing
number of accolades
way too many to list here.
But it's worth noting that she is listed
as one of the top 100
most influential people
in Business Ethics by Ethisphere Magazine.
I'll point out that this is a list
that also includes
people like Pope Francis,
Angelina Jolie and Bill Gates,
you get a sense of her
kind of influence here.
She's also an amazing teacher.
She's been one of the most highly rated
Business School professors
at NYU for a long time.
And just this year,
she received the 2020 NYU
Distinguished Teaching Award.
She's just an amazing
teacher and an amazing mentor
and an amazing person
in terms of her impact.
And today, we're really
gonna kind of dive deep
into her work.
We're gonna talk not just about
the kinds of things we need to do
to focus on becoming better people,
but we're gonna explore
how her work demonstrates
that all of us really need to step it up
if we wanna kind of create the change
that we wanna see in our world.
If we wanna have just societies
and just organizations
and just universities, then we
really need to do something.
And one of the things we need to do
is to understand the biases
that we're all walking around with.
We need to hack those biases
and understand how they work
so that we can become better people.
And so with that, I'm super
excited to introduce Dolly.
I'm such a huge fan and I'm thrilled
that Yale has brought her here today.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Dolly Chugh.
- Hi, Laurie.
- Thanks so much for coming again.
- Oh, my God!
- So I wanted to start out
with maybe what's an obvious question.
So, you know, we have a
lot of people on this call,
but I hope I can speak for
all of them when I say that
everybody on this call, like
truly cares about equity,
like everybody on this call, I hope,
believes that people from
all races, all ethnicities,
all body statuses, all that stuff,
should be treated equally.
But what you argue in your book
is that that belief in equity isn't enough
and is, in fact, part of the problem.
So, what we rewired
believing isn't enough.
- Oh, okay. Great.
Thank you for having
me, Laurie, colleagues,
it's wonderful to be here.
Well, I talked about this difference
between being a believer and a builder.
And I say this from a place, frankly,
seeing myself in exactly
what I'm about to describe.
So, as you just listed,
there's a whole range of ways
in which a lot of us want to see equality
and even equity in the world around us.
And we believe that's what should happen.
We also are believers,
that that doesn't exist.
So we don't have to be convinced,
we may not be deeply
informed on every issue
and every identity, but we
know that things aren't quite
where we want them to be.
We're believers in that sense.
The challenge, however,
is that the status quo
doesn't change based on
our beliefs, necessarily,
particularly if were
really kind of invested
in being the kind of
people who believe that
and I think I am, I really
wanna be the kind of person
who treats people well,
that creates opportunities
for people who haven't had opportunities,
I wanna be that kind of believer.
However, in order to do it, I
have to build certain things,
I have to build knowledge,
I have to build skills,
I have to build systems,
I have to build courage,
I have to build habits,
these are all active modes of operating,
that won't happen just
because I believe something.
So just because I believe every
student in my class at NYU,
should be treated equally,
should have an equal opportunity
to succeed in my class,
that doesn't mean that
I have built a system
in which that can happen.
And with that, I built a classroom
in which everyone feels equally welcome.
That I built a grading protocol
in which everyone has
the possibility to excel,
that I've built a culture
in which people feel
they can come talk to me
if they have a question.
Those are all actions I have to take.
So the distinction between
believing and building
are really, I shouldn't
call it distinction
that continuum between moving
through being a believer
to a builder, for me is
about taking actions.
And the challenge with
when we don't do that,
when we sit in that
believer end of the pool,
is that we get comfortable.
We care so much about this issue,
that we develop an identity
as being someone supportive of this issue,
but not doing anything about it.
And if someone says, "Hey, how about...
I noticed the ways in which
maybe you're contributing
to the challenge..."
Like if my teaching assistant says to me,
"I noticed that your calling patterns
reflect you calling on
men more than women."
Which happens. That's true.
Then I'm gonna get
defensive, because I'm like,
"Well, no, I believe in
equity in my classroom."
Rather than building saying,
"Ah, okay, now I have data.
What can I do with this data?
What can I do to change
my calling patterns?
What can I do to make it possible
for more people to have their hands up?"
That's what the builder responses
as opposed to the believer response.
- And I think this is so
important, because again, you know,
I'm sure everybody who's coming to this
is coming from this place of
like caring about this stuff.
- Yes.
- I think that's super
important that the caring alone,
it's not just like, not helpful,
it could actually be
deeply counterproductive
to some interesting extent.
- And in fact, it feels like abandonment,
I think, when we're part of the groups
that are dealing with this,
if you're a black student at Yale,
and your white classmates
believe in all this
but aren't taking action on
it, it feels like abandonment.
It doesn't feel like supportive.
Oh, I am not, of course
speaking for everyone,
but in general that's the perception
that both science and
anecdotes would suggest.
So, that's the danger of being a believer
is that it feels shallow,
we're in the shallow end of the pool.
- And so you've talked about
a couple different ways
that we can kind of dive into
the deeper end of the pool.
That there's kind of
different ways to be a builder
with a kind of like
really hardcore building
and it kind of softer type of building.
So talk about, in your book,
you make this distinction
between light and heat.
Which I think is a really great analogy.
So walk me through kind of
the light version of building
versus the heat version of building.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And I'm gonna preface this by saying
it's the most important
thing about light and heat
is to know that we need both.
Let me define what each of them mean.
I'm using a metaphor, I
wasn't able to track down
who originally came up with
this light/heat metaphor
is widely used.
The idea of, when you take
a light based approach
to let's say, making
change in your community,
or in your institution, you
meet people where they are,
you center their comfort,
you educate, you teach.
It's slower, and it's more incremental.
A heat based approach to making change
is one in which by definition
is not centering the comfort of others,
it is pushing, it is disruptive.
And it's meant to push for change faster
in a more dramatic ways.
Most of us, my sense is kind of lean
in terms of our personal preferences
towards more light or more heat.
Some people are good at both
and comfortable with both.
But like I would say,
I tend to lean towards the
light based approaches.
But this was a really,
I would say, probably the
most important learning
I had from writing this
book was realizing that
just because I am more
comfortable with light,
doesn't mean that I don't,
I shouldn't see the value in heat.
What historians have showed us,
historians of social movements,
is that, when a movement sort
of leans heavily on light,
or leans heavily on heat,
versus movements that balance both,
the movements that balance
both make more progress.
So, the message here,
and this is why I feel
it's so important for me to learn this
is just because I am a light based person
doesn't mean that I
shouldn't be cheering on
the heat based folks.
And just because I'm a heat based person,
doesn't mean I shouldn't be
cheering on the light base.
We often feel the tactics
being used by the others
aren't what we would do
and aren't as effective,
but one of the differences
that light and heat has
and why we need both
is that light may be more
likely to change minds,
but it's probably not
gonna change systems.
Heat is probably more
likely to change systems
and less likely to change minds.
Well, we need both.
We need both our minds
and our systems to move
in order for real change to happen.
And so, I think in this
work of being a builder,
sometimes we preference, you
know, because I'm right handed,
I want everyone to be right handed
or because I'm left, I
want everybody left handed.
But know, what we want is like bass people
to cheer on the heat bass people
and heat bass people to cheer
on the light bass people.
And frankly, it's all good.
Wherever you are in that space,
as long as you're not in the inaction.
You know, that's back to being a believer,
I don't know, keep the
metaphor going like dark,
notice if you will, or
silence or something.
But the light and heat are both important.
It's particularly important
that we cheer on the heat.
I don't have data on this,
but I bet there's more light
base people in your community,
than there are heat based.
And boy, you should be grateful
that you have those heat base, folks.
- That's perfect.
And so, I mean, so both of us
need to kind of as you said,
"Get past the darkness."
Like we need the light heat,
but people can be sort of
sitting around in the dark.
And so-
- Right.
- One of the first skill
sets you present in the book
for getting people out of the darkness,
and again, the darkness is
believing in equity, right?
It's like things just
like that (indistinct)
The first step is really kind
of learning something, right?
It's actually recognizing
the sorts of privileges
that you have.
And so, just give me a tricky concept
for people who haven't talked
a lot about this before.
So walk me through this idea
of privilege, what that means.
- Yeah, I struggle with this too.
It's tied a lot to another
tricky word, which is systemic.
I think these words go hand in hand
and are hard to understand.
The metaphor that helped me with that
comes from Debbie Irving.
She uses a metaphor of
headwinds and tailwind
that I find really useful.
So, I'm looking over there
to make sure my kids aren't eavesdropping,
'cause they'll always laugh
with the little example
I'm about to give you.
So the example is, let's
say I was to go running...
That's when they start laughing.
Like, "Oh, let's say..."
So let's say I go running and
I say, "Okay, I'm gonna run
to the high school on the
corner, have a good jog,
and then I'm gonna u-turn
and come right back the way I came."
And while I'm making my way over there,
I'm feeling pretty good.
I'm going, you know,
I think there's no carb
things working out.
I'm feeling pretty strong,
you know, make a good time.
And then I turn around for the U turn
and suddenly things feel
harder and more effortful.
And if someone's was just like
inside their home or office
and watching me through a window,
they might, if they
just see me coming back,
be like, "Doesn't even look
like she's trying that hard
or she doesn't look that motivated
or I don't know she
comes from a community,
doesn't really value running.
I see she's just not taking it seriously."
They wouldn't see what I'm
feeling which is a headwind
in my face on the way back.
And on my way there,
that tailwind which was
propelling me forward,
I didn't even feel 'cause you
don't really feel tailwinds,
you benefit from them,
but you don't feel them.
And so, the headwinds are more easily felt
than the tailwinds.
And all of it is sort
of invisible in general
and hard to see.
And that's, I think, a
good way to think about
what privilege is, is
that at any given moment,
any one of us has some form of privilege
on some form of our their identities.
Like, "I'm straight.
And while I don't spend a lot of time
thinking about my straightness,
because frankly I don't have to.
The world is kind of, police community
in the society I live in
makes it pretty easy to be straight.
It doesn't create obstacles for me,
I have lots of legal rights.
I have lots of physical safety."
That privilege that I have,
that tailwind is one I don't
even really think about
versus the headwind that
if someone isn't straight,
they're constantly navigating.
And so when we talk about privilege,
what we're really talking about
are where do we have tailwinds.
And each of us have multiple identities
and therefore multiple
headwinds and tailwinds.
Right now, I think in 2020,
we've had an opportunity.
There's been headwinds, if
you are a black American,
there are headwinds that
have been very visible
and felt by people in the black community
that haven't been felt
and seen and experienced
by many people outside
the black community.
And that became visible in a new way
in this year for many people,
some people already know.
So that privilege is sort
of one in which we're now
tuning into in a way that maybe
at a widespread countrywide basis,
we haven't done in the past.
- But this is kind of the key
of these headwinds and tailwinds
is that the both of them are invisible.
I guess the headwinds are very visible,
if you're being slowed down by them
they're incredibly visible to you.
But if you're not from
a marginalized identity,
or one of your identities
is not marginalized,
you just don't see it.
What I love about your
book is that you point out
that this is true for you, too, right?
Like you do out on it.
And it's still hard to see these things.
- Absolutely.
Like I have so many
tailwinds and, you know,
whether it's me not realizing, you know,
I'm the child of Indian immigrants.
So I was born in India,
but a baby when my parents came here,
and, you know, I don't know what...
Like, I'm not sure how people identify me,
I think I pass as a lot of things.
That privileges me.
I get considered a person
of color in some circles
in a way that privileges me
when I'm with other people of color.
And I think some people
see me as white maybe,
and I sort of pass in those circles.
There's lots of ways, you know,
the straightness is another example.
I think, you know, my education
level, my native language,
I'm cisgender.
None of these identities are
better than other identities.
I'm not in any way saying I'm lucky
to have those identities,
but I do incur benefits as a
result of those identities,
my education, my income level,
I'm constantly surprised at
the things I'm oblivious to,
you know, that the fact, you know,
most recently, the set of
awareness that I've gained
is around my physical
abilities and disabilities.
And realizing there's
lots of ways in which
I have just not even noticed
how the world is not set up
for students in my community
in my classes who are disabled.
And that's despite supposedly,
like legal accommodations that we make,
that really, I can tell
you in my classroom
have not been sufficient.
And so, I've just recently
realized there's all these ways
in which I've made learning
harder for my students
that I could have been addressing,
like using captions on Zoom.
Like when we were teaching in person
using captions on videos.
I mean, those are just too many ways.
So these privileges that
are like that's a headwind
I was just not seeing at all.
Yeah, and so when you
bring up those examples,
I think, you know, everybody
who has those cases
where they kind of
notice, like spots where,
"Wow, I was just having it so much easier
than I even realized that I'm
making inadvertently harder
for the people around me."
And I had some hand in it, right?
It's not just the system like,
the videos I posted for my
class had that same feature.
Sometimes, like one bad
thing about privilege
is that it's invisible.
But the second bad thing about privilege
is that when you notice it, it
feels incredibly bad, right?
Like, even in cases where
you didn't have a hand in it,
like you feel kind of awful.
Like, I didn't try to get these tail winds
that are making me speed past everyone.
And so, talk about that
feature of privilege, right?
'Cause I think, you know, a
lot of us don't like feeling
like we're getting these tail winds that
are kind of helping us out a lot.
And what does that do to our psychology?
- Yeah, I mean, it's
pretty mortifying, right.
And there's research that shows
that we actually, we like to get things
but we sort of like to feel
like we do we deserve it
and we earned it, right.
Like, we don't like to feel
like we unfairly got something.
And so, yeah, it feels awful.
I think where we make a lot of headway,
when we have those moments of insight
is if we can sort of in
the mental accounting
of that noticing, put
it in the growth bucket.
This is a place of growth.
And so, you know, one thing
I've been talking about lately
is like, if you can't think
about a TV show, or a joke,
or word that you watched or
used or laughed at, a year ago,
or five years ago, that
you're now mortified by,
I'm gonna argue that you're not growing,
you're not learning.
If you feel like everything
you've ever said,
done or watched is sort of
aligned with who you are now
and what you know now,
that says to me, there's like
this very static, you know,
brittle, almost good person
identity that isn't evolving.
In most aspects of our life,
we try to get better all the time.
You try a recipe you haven't
tried before, it work,
you try to master a
software system or whatever.
In this one area of being
a good person, though,
we view every mistake as
a complete condemnation,
a complete sort of blanket of shame.
You know, I sort of feel
myself kind of get warm
and sweaty in those moments.
But what's really helped me
and the research by Carol
Dweck, psychologists
and her co author supports this,
is if we can view things as growth,
not sort of in a fixed
mindset as she describes it,
in which we have nowhere to go,
but we actually view, "Oh, I just noticed,
like those videos, that
was deeply problematic.
That was something I should have known.
I shouldn't have had...
By the way, that was an email
that I probably dismissed about it.
Like I really had to be nudged."
That's a moment for me to say,
"Okay, I now know more
than I did a year ago,
and five years ago, and I'm acting on it."
So I think we miss an opportunity
to actually feel great about
ourselves in that moment.
Not feel great that we noticed and stopped
but that we noticed and learned.
(indistinct)
- This idea that you talked
a lot about in your book
about not wanting to be a good person,
but being a good ish person,
which I think people can misconstrue
when you say, "Don't worry
about being a good person
when it comes to justice."
And explain to me what
you mean by good ish
'cause I think it's so important.
- Yeah, thank you. I I've
got to be more precise.
I've learned on that than
I've been in the past.
Okay, so the campaign Ahmad
is to get us to stop
trying to be good people.
But that's not because I want
us to lower our standards.
I'm actually making the
opposite argument that
in our good person identities
are a fixed mindset identity.
They're deeply brittle.
There's no stretch there
to grow and get better.
In a growth mindset, which in this domain,
I would say it's called being goodish.
We're actually actively
looking for those mistakes.
It's an Easter egg hunt.
They're out there, go find the candy.
Candy. That's the wrong.
That was a terrible metaphor.
But, go find the learnings.
Because when you do, that's
where the growth happens.
And so this goodish, what
I'm defining as good ish,
is being someone who's actively noticing
and actually seeking out those learnings.
So, you know, we know from the
studies around growth mindset
that when you make a
mistake in a fixed mindset,
we actually see brain
activity kind of shut down,
you actually don't attend to the mistake,
you literally withdraw mental attention.
Versus if you're in a growth mindset,
and you make that mistake,
we see all sorts of activity in the brain
in a way that suggests
like, you may be mortified,
but boy, are you going
to soak up what you can
from this moment?
And that's soaking up what you can
that's what I mean by goodish.
I don't mean like, oh, too bad.
Like, I guess I'm not, you know,
I mean, the exact opposite.
Like I am gonna own this.
Thank you for telling me that.
Oh, wow. I had no idea.
I'm gonna go look that up,
I appreciate you bringing
it to my attention.
That's the kind of outcome.
- And that's where this idea
that kind of feeling like
we've messed up, feels yucky,
is problematic because one
thing can cause us to do is,
if we don't have mechanisms
to have a growth mindset
and kind of get over that yucky feeling,
it can cause us to do
a number of bad things.
One of them is just to deny
that we've messed up at all.
Right?
- Right.
Absolutely. Yeah.
And that's, of course,
you know, the most harmful
because not only are we not learning,
if the context in which that
happening is someone saying,
if I have a student saying to me,
I think that reading you assign,
like, there was just
nothing but white voices
represented in that reading.
And I kind of like dismiss,
"Well, you don't understand my field."
Which, by the way, is exactly the dialogue
that goes through my mind.
How dare you and don't you know,
but when I can sort of like poop,
there it is, those are my red flags.
Those are my triggers.
That's my good person responding.
When I can flip it, you
know, to not deny them,
I'm actually also now creating a space
where their lived experience is valued
as opposed to doing double harm.
First, I made the mistake.
And then I told them,
their lived experience wasn't legitimate.
I said to them, "Well, it's
not raining where I am.
So I guess it's not
raining where you are."
That's what I do with denial.
- And the key with that
is that you have to have this vision,
first of all, but you
don't have to fight it.
Because it doesn't mean
you're a bad person.
It's giving you this opportunity
to learn something new,
which is actually cool.
You can be this like nerd
in the like social justice classroom
where you're like, "Oh, this is the thing
that wasn't on my radar yet,
how can I learn to do better there?"
- I think that's a great way to put it.
I never thought of it that way.
But I think that's sort
of what I've become.
It's not that I don't like
sometimes lay awake at night,
mortified by it.
And it's by no means a
game, but there's this like,
satisfaction with getting better at it.
And knowing that the harm
I've done in the past
I can lessen that in the future.
- It's worth noting that this is hard.
I mean, a lot of the
social psychology research
suggests it's really easy to fall
into these fixed mindset patterns
where we kind of go off and deny stuff.
And so just to get some of
the science on the table,
talk to me about one of these ways
that we end up denying privilege
in this interesting way
and which has a funny name,
it's called this bias
called "A Hard Knock Life."
Let's just talk through that
to get it on the table here.
- Oh, sure. I love that study.
It's by my colleague, Taylor Phillips
set at NYU and her co author,
Brian Lowry at Stanford.
I love that paper.
So, what they talk about
with the heart nightlife effect...
So, first, this context,
the phrase 'hard knock life'
is referring to a song
in a Broadway musical
in a movie called "Annie."
- Don't worry. (laughs)
- You sing it
♪ It's a hard-knock life for us ♪
- Folks, thank you for coming.
That's awesome, Laurie.
Anyway, that's the third
time I've got someone to sing
live in the last week
on a Zoom of some sort.
So I'm keeping track.
So in the song that you just heard,
"It's a hard knock life,"
it refers to this sort of the challenges,
adversity that one's face,
particularly in childhood.
So in this particular set of studies,
what they did was they asked people
to think about their childhood
and to reflect on the hardships
and adversity of their childhoods.
But the variable that they
manipulated in their studies
is sometimes they just ask people to do it
and sometimes, and I believe,
can't remember if they
ran white participants
and black participants,
but they definitely have white
participants in the study.
So, in one condition, they simply said,
"Tell me about your childhood
and diversity and what..."
And in the other condition,
the instructions were slightly different
for those participants.
Before they said, "Tell
me about your childhood."
They gave them a quick little sentence
that said something about the advantages
that white people have had
versus blacks in the United States.
And so it's basically a statement
of what we would call group advantage,
something you individually
had those advantages,
but as a group.
And what then? They looked
at what the responses were.
And what they found
was the people essentially
rewrote their personal histories.
It doesn't even appear that it
was necessarily a conscious,
like, they don't have evidence,
there was a conscious process,
but then they literally
cited more challenges
and more adversity in their lives
in the condition where they were reminded
of group advantage.
And so, what I take
away from these studies
is this, how hard our minds will work,
even without us directing it consciously
to protect our identities,
that good person identity,
that deserving person identity,
that I have not taken any
advantage away from anyone else.
And so, in those studies,
what people were revealing,
I think if I remember,
right, in the papers,
they were, the scholars were saying that
while group advantage,
a lot of people buy into group advantage,
they found evidence that people
didn't necessarily dispute
that there were these group
advantages based on race.
What they resisted was
that they individually
incurred that group advantage.
And so that's where this hard knock life
retelling of our personal
histories kicks in.
There's some like, work
we have to do around.
We intellectually understand
a lot of this data,
but do we really internally accept
that we may be beneficiaries of it,
that we may be, in fact,
even propagating it.
And the data suggests we are.
We are beneficiaries and we
are propagating it, you know,
depending on what dimension of
identity we're talking about,
but if we're not black,
we're probably benefiting
from some biases,
racial biases that are
deeply hurting others.
- And in the power that, you
know, without us realizing it,
our minds are just gonna go to data,
like, they're just
gonna look up statistics
that make us feel like we personally
couldn't have been as privileged,
like other white people,
other streets and wall, you know,
other, you know, Ivy
League, you know, employees,
like they benefit, but not me, personally.
- That right.
- Absolutely.
This is all in a domain of, you know,
trying to have a growth mindset
so that when things
are pointed out to you,
like, you can not deny them,
you cannot try to like, you know,
find other evidence and so on.
But there are other ways
that are kind of good person
mindset gets in the way too,
even in cases where
we're like trying to act.
And that's kind of what
you refer to in the book
as something like cookie seeking.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
So talk a little bit about this,
'cause these are cases where,
we're not denying like,
we're trying to take action to fix things.
But we're doing this in a way that's like,
a little bit kind of benefiting us,
rather than the people
we're trying to help.
- Yes, absolutely.
Yeah, so the freeze cookies, again,
is another one where I don't
know who to attribute it to,
we tried hard to figure
out the original source,
but it's a phrase that
is used pretty widely
in activist communities.
And it speaks to this
centering we sometimes do.
So, you know, let's say,
I have a black colleague,
and, you know, I've lately
been trying to educate myself,
I went and read "The New Jim Crow."
I read "Cast," I read "The
Warmth of Other Suns."
So, I sort of somehow find a way
to work it into my conversation.
In this example, I'm not
black. I'm me, I'm not black.
I somehow find a way to
work it into a conversation
with my black colleague, you know,
'cause I'm sort of waiting for them.
You know, again, it may
not be totally conscious,
but, I say it and then I like
do that little micro pause,
where you're waiting to be
like, "Oh, oh, good for you."
Like, that's a little bit of
a cookie seeking behavior.
You know, I noticed myself even doing it,
like outside of issues around identity
even in like my own marriage, you know,
my husband right now, during the pandemic,
his work is outside the home.
So really, I should be
feeling bad for him.
He's, you know, an
essential worker out there.
But, instead, I'm home with the kids.
And so when he gets home, I
sort of do all sorts of like,
I don't overtly whine.
But I kind of drop in
a whole bunch of like,
how hard today was kind of little weeding
with those little micro
pauses to be validated,
to be given a cookie.
And that's all fine and good,
except for the fact that
what I've just done there
is instead of centering the
people I'm trying to support,
if we go back to my black colleague,
I'm reading those books,
because I am trying to do
better when it comes to racism.
But instead, what I've done
is just added to the burden of racism,
because I've now asked this colleague
to see me and validate
me and it's exhausting.
And it happens on a constant basis,
in big ways and small ways.
That's what cookie seeking is.
And the story I tell in the book about it
is a former student of mine, actually,
who identifies as queer
and worked at the time
in a very progressive
company in San Francisco
in the Bay Area.
And the Orlando police shooting happened.
You might remember we woke
up that Sunday morning
to that news.
She was grief, stricken all day Sunday
and then a Sunday night approached,
and she thought about
going to work on Monday,
and a company that had all
sorts of progressive policies
and progressive people and like, you know,
she was dreading going to work.
Why was she dreading?
Not because people wouldn't care,
not because there would be bigotry,
but because there would
be so much cookie seeking.
She knew everybody will be coming to her,
trying to be seen, trying to be validated.
"Oh, you know, I am donating
to the Trevor Project
for years, or, you know,
my gay college roommate."
And she felt she had no
more emotional reserves
to support them, that she
needed to be seen and heard,
rather than helping them be seen or heard.
So that's what cookie seeking refers to.
- Yeah, and I think that this is something
that comes up a lot, I
think, for our black students
and staff members in the context of
what we've been going through in 2020,
where, again, well intentioned people
who are believers in equity,
but because they kind of have that,
"I wanna be seen as a
good person mindset."
End up putting more emotional
labor on black people,
because they're trying to like,
show off how woke they are
about these kinds of things.
- Exactly, well said.
- And so, all of these things
from denying the privilege to
kind of seeking out some data
that makes you feel better
about your privilege,
Oh, it wasn't me to sort
of hard knock like effect.
Even the cookie seeking,
these are all cases where like,
'cause we really, really
wanna be a good person,
we like deeply get it wrong,
even though we're a believer.
And so now I want to stretch
to strategies we can use
to like be the builder, right?
Like not just rely on the giving part,
and kind of use that goodish mindset
to kind of get a little bit further.
And so I wanna start with
that on the privilege side
about just the act of seeing it.
So what are some tips,
given that we know we're likely to deny it
or just lots of things about
the headwinds and tailwinds
mean, we don't see these things,
what can you do to like, you
know, actually look there,
to kind of take your spy
goggles on and put it on
and see the privilege and the structures
that you're benefiting from?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think the first thing we can do
is really just start noticing
what's happening around us.
I mean, this is the classic,
you know, yesterday,
I said, you know, "Gosh, for some reason,
we have no pens in this house,
can I find a working pen?"
And my husband says,
"Oh, I just bought some pens,
they're in the junk drawers."
I open the junk drawer and I'm like,
"There is no pens in this junk drawer."
Like I am looking, there's no any.
He comes over and he's like,
"Yeah, you mean this
entire pack of big pens
right in front of you!"
So part of it is we got to start seeing
the big pens right in front of us.
And the way I think we
can do that as some audits
around what is like the daily
consumption we're doing?
So whatever it is, you consume,
movies, podcasts, TV shows,
music, you read, whatever...
We're all consuming
something in some form, news.
Audit the last 10 units
of that that you did.
How much diversity of voice is in there?
How much diversity of identity?
How similar are those
identities to your own?
Look at your social media...
Sorry, I forgot to say,
social media is a really
big piece of consumption
for many of us.
One really concrete place
we can start is to say,
let's audit my last 10 units
of x and figure out if in fact,
there isn't enough range of perspectives
and identities in there
and nothing different from ourselves.
And for almost all of us, there isn't.
I can actively start changing that.
That's an action we can easily take.
By doing that, we start to notice things
we haven't noticed before.
You know, I tell a story in the
book about when I was a kid,
I had parents sort of
passed down this clock radio
that was that was broken.
And it turned out where it broke
was on a particular black radio station.
And so as a young kid, I
didn't really understand
that there were like
different radio stations
for white music and black music.
So, I grew up hearing like
black talk radio in the morning
and black music, of course,
but also black tellings of news events.
And, of course, it was a wide
range of black perspectives
that I heard on that station.
And when I got old enough to realize
that there was more than one
radio station in the world
and that other radio stations
where sort of saying different things,
it was this like mo noticing moment.
So I'd say, right there is
one place we can start today
to begin to notice things
we haven't seen before
the perspectives we
haven't tuned into before.
And last thing I'll say on that,
particularly if it's on social
media that you're doing this,
when we start to tune in to conversations
we weren't hearing before,
it's very important that we treat it
as if you were eavesdropping
in a coffee shop,
chances are by politeness norms,
you wouldn't insert your
self into that conversation.
You are a guest, you're an eavesdropper.
So, the opportunity is
to listen not to argue,
not to justify, not to say
all white people, all women,
all men, whatever.
It's Simply to pick up
stuff we're not hearing.
- And I think another thing you
said in that piece of advice
I wanted to kind of like double down on,
which is that you said, kind
of consuming these things,
you didn't say, you know, talk
to your one queer colleague
about what it's like to be queer
or demand that your black colleague, like,
explain to you how she's feeling
after the most recent police shooting.
Like there's content that
already exists out there,
you shouldn't ask people
for emotional labor
to tell you what to look at.
- That's right.
There's no shortage of...
Which isn't to say that
we should be silent,
what we wanna do is, if
there's a terrible shooting
of an unarmed black person,
there is value in saying
to a black colleague,
"I just want you to know,
I'm thinking of you and your family.
Is there anything I can do to support you?
Is there anything I can
take off your plate today?
Like, I just want you to know,
I don't know how you're doing today.
But I just want you to know, I see you."
There may be value in that,
of course, you have to judge
the individual relationship and context.
So, silence is actually quite
destructive those moments,
but that's different than saying,
"Can you tell me how you feel
when you get pulled over?"
I mean, like, that's asking a lot.
Then why don't understand.
But if you just, you know,
put your hands, you know,
like, that's emotional labor.
- Right, right. And so
that's one distinction.
But I think a bigger thing
I think we need to do
to kind of be builders is like
how we deal with the moments
when our mistakes are pointed out.
And one of the things,
I think you're incredibly
frank about in the book,
is that one of the reasons we
can't be good people right now
is that we're probably all gonna mess up.
You're not yourself, if you
are yourself from any identity
that is not marginalized.
Because of the headwind tailwind thing,
you're not gonna see stuff,
and you are gonna screw up.
Is that?
- 100%.
I had a conversation with somebody
I really respect last week,
who is reading my book,
or it just was in the
middle of reading my book
when I spoke to her.
This is someone I don't know well.
I know of her.
And this was the first time
I was speaking with her.
And she said, "Can I share
with you? I love your book.
But I noticed you centre whiteness?"
And I was like, "Oh! All right.
What do you mean by that?"
And she proceeded to read a
section of my book aloud to me,
in which it was really clear,
I had centered whiteness
in the way I had done it
is I had in that particular
section of the book.
I hadn't even like named
that I was doing it.
But I was speaking to white people,
without even naming I was doing it.
It was just sort of as if
the default is whiteness,
and so I can now speak to
you without even saying,
"Okay, white readers,
this little bit might be more
useful to you than to others."
I did not do that consciously.
That is not the type of
book I meant to write.
And yet, I'm not at all
surprised it happens, you know,
I have also grown up trying to, you know,
fit in into a community of whiteness.
So, the response in that
moment is really critical
of I felt the fixed mindset rising,
but because I know to
look for it, I was like,
"Oh, my gosh! What a gift."
That's the moment I have saved myself,
"What a gift. What a gift."
She's telling me, "What a gift."
She's probably the million
person who thought it
but she's the one who's
actually telling me.
- Walk me through kind of
what are the right reactions
in those cases?
Because I'm sure everybody
again, everybody on this webinar
is gonna experience it for some identity
that they might not see themselves.
- Yeah, absolutely.
If the situation is something
like the one I just gave,
or somebody like live, or you
know, an email or whatever,
giving you information
about something they
noticed that you didn't,
that's the key moment to say,
first and foremost, it buys you time,
and it's what you mean.
Thank you.
Thank you, first and foremost.
Wow, thank you.
The second thing to say is,
"I wanna understand what you're saying."
If you don't understand what
they're saying, you know,
can you tell me like,
"Oh, you center whiteness in the book."
"Wow, thank you. Can you tell
me where you saw me do that?"
The person may have
the stamina to do that.
And they may not.
And if they don't, that's
not on them. It's on me.
But if you can get an example
not because you're like,
"Oh, well prove it."
It's more like, "Oh,
wow, I am really grateful
you saw something, I did it."
So language like, "Thank
you. Can you tell me more?
I'm sorry."
Let's not underestimate the
power of those three words.
"I am sorry."
I wanna be clear. It's three words.
It's not, "I am sorry,
that that I offended you."
Or, "I am sorry. You were offended."
Or, "I am sorry."
No, it's "I am sorry."
We have to own our impact,
even when it doesn't match our intention.
In fact, it's especially
when it doesn't match our intention.
So I am sorry, I want to learn
more about that, you know,
meaning I'm going to go
learn more about that,
or that's really useful for me.
I'm gonna educate myself on that,
or I'm gonna go, review things
I've written in the past
and see if I made that
same mistake, or, you know,
when I have some data I could
look at to see, you know,
you're saying that my
grading doesn't feel good,
I'm gonna actually go back
and look at past grading
and see if in fact, that
pattern does show up.
And thank you for giving
me something to test.
In the data I have, we all have data,
no matter what you do for a living,
you have some, whatever
you do is, in fact data,
your daily actions and
daily behaviors are data,
you may or may not be collecting
it and documenting it.
But that is, in fact, data
that you could look at.
So, let me look at it. Let
me learn more about it.
Thank you, I am sorry.
These are all great places
to start that conversation.
- And so that's kind of when you mess up
which is so important to
kind of react correctly,
because we're going to mess up.
But there are other things
we need to do as a builder,
which is to step up, right?
Which is to maybe be the one pointing out
when we notice other cases of bias
or when we notice other cases of mistreat.
And you talk when somebody
who's not themselves
from a marginalized
group, points this out,
you talk about that in terms of
what's called ordinary privilege.
And so walk us through ordinary privilege
and kind of why it's so important
that people from non
marginalized identities
use that to fix things.
- Yeah, absolutely.
So this brings us back a little bit
to our headwinds and tailwind.
So, you know, if we think of privilege
as the places where we
have the tail winds,
and then I'm going to
call ordinary privilege
is the places where I have the tailwinds
that are so ordinary
in my day to day life,
I don't even think about them.
So straightness,
for me is in the form
of ordinary privilege,
I don't have to think about it,
because I don't have to navigate
it, as I mentioned earlier.
And so those parts of our identity
that we, I think,
there's a national
conversation around privilege,
where we might feel shame
around that identity,
if we're willing to acknowledge it,
I'm actually heartened by the studies,
the many studies that show
that we actually that ordinary
privilege gives us influence.
And so, for example, there's
studies that show that
if a racist joke is told,
and a white person says,
"Hey, that wasn't cool."
Versus a black person says,
Controlling for all the things we control
for in good rigorous experiments,
the black person will
not be taken as seriously
than the white person who
challenges the racist joke.
That there's an attribution made
of entitlement or whining us.
Even though it was the same
joke and the same response.
So, what can we take from that?
Well, the white person might be like,
"It's not my place to speak up on this."
So they might think, I
shouldn't say anything.
But what the data is saying,
is that actually, you have more influence
than probably, A, you realize
and B than the black person.
Well, in this moment,
it doesn't mean I should
talk over the black person.
But it does mean that I shouldn't
be silenced or accepting.
And in that moment, I think
we have ordinary privilege
that we can access the
part of my identity,
I think about least, which possibly
for some white people might be their race,
that might not be the first
thing that comes to mind,
when you think of your identity.
That might be the exact place
where you have more influence
than you realize your ordinary privilege.
- And it's also just kind of,
it's made perhaps more effective,
or at least that's what the data suggests.
It's more effective, in
this case of a racist joke,
if you're a white person, you speak up.
It's also like, hopeful
and that like, you know,
it sucks more, like if
you're the black person
who's sitting there when a
racist joke is being told
or racist statements being said, right?
Like, there's just such emotional labor
that you go through to become
a marginalized identity
than to like, take that
labor off the plate
of the marginalized person,
could be incredibly powerful,
and all these contexts from
race, gender, and all this.
- Exactly. And that's exactly right.
And then the third benefit
I will add to that,
is that, it looks like
we tend to underestimate,
we think, oh, it's not going
to matter if I say anything,
the person is gonna get
defensive or argue with me
or belittle me.
And that's true. That often does happen.
But with studies also show is
there does seem to be an impact, though,
in the behavior of the individual.
Not always, I'm not claiming
this is always gonna happen.
We interpret a defensive
response as we got nowhere,
the data suggests otherwise.
- That's great to hear.
And that was actually I would say,
one of the most common
questions we received
before this webinar is,
this question of like,
how do I engage when I
hear these tiny micro,
not tiny but like, you know,
important questions at work?
You know, how do I like point out bias
without seeming holier than thou,
I guess that's an interesting
thing that these data shows,
that as the point or outter,
you're focused again, kind of on yourself,
like, I don't want to
seem holier than thou,
I don't wanna seem like a
snob or it's not my place.
But actually, if you're
in a good ish mindset,
where you're paying attention
to his outcome, right,
like you want these behaviors to stop,
you wanna fight these
systems and the structures
that make things feel so unequal
for people from different backgrounds.
- I think that's exactly right.
If we're centering around comfort,
we're not willing to
spend some of that comfort
than that we are centering ourselves.
I mean, there is value,
though, and thinking about,
again, back to heat and light,
like, let's be intentional,
if that's for you going
to be a light base moment
where you actually wanna change minds,
then you're gonna have
to think about like,
what influence strategies
are you gonna use,
if that's gonna be a heat based moment
where you just want to
make the other person
very uncomfortable and
challenge what they did
and puncture the norm, then
then you can take that approach
and be effective in that kind of way.
But absolutely, in that moment,
when the opportunity to speak up happens,
if we wait for it to feel comfortable,
we almost never will.
- And that I think is just a message
that I think everyone on this
call needs to hear, right?
Like, this is supposed to
be uncomfortable, right?
- Yeah.
- It is almost always uncomfortable
for people from certain identities, right?
Like they don't get to
avoid this discomfort.
- That's exactly right. And
I'm so glad you said that.
I was trying to like string
that thought together
and didn't quite get there.
Exactly.
If the discomfort of living in a society
where racism occurs on a daily basis
is being borne by black people,
and they can't walk away from that,
then why should the rest of us
be able to walk away from that?
That is, in fact, what privilege means.
- Right. And so we kind
of have to dive in.
And so then, let's get to get to some,
like practical strategies
for the final kind of
thing we talked about,
that we can end up doing, if
we're in that good mindset
that we don't wanna do,
which is the the cookie
seeking stuff, right?
Like, kind of centering yourself as,
"Hey, I'm this whole person,
and I'm trying to do good."
How do we get over that?
- Yeah, well, I mean, the
first thing is like just
stepping into...
Okay, let's do it this way.
Like, everybody, right
now, think about something
that you've gotten better at, you know,
like, baking, basketball,
anything, Bulgarian,
like, I'm trying to go with the bees.
Whatever, think of just
take a moment in your mind,
think of the thing you got better at
and think about how it
felt at the beginning,
when you started doing it,
and then how it felt as you got better.
And if you were to sort
of come up with one word
to describe like the emotion of that.
And when I do this with students,
they see things like exhilarating or proud
or struggle or a better, you know,
that's the feeling we
wanna have in this domain.
And we can.
What we tend to have this
domain is feelings like shame,
and you know, discouragement or confusion
and things like that.
So we wanna replace like, we
really want to come at this
from a place of, it feels good
to get better at something,
and I can get better at this.
This is being good ish.
This is a growth mindset.
And then, once we do that, like,
I think we can begin to act in ways
that we haven't acted on before
that aren't cookie seeking,
instead of sort of showing
to others what we're doing,
we're now almost like, you
know, showing to ourselves,
we're seeking the cookie from ourselves,
if that makes any sense,
that we are in fact, noticing
things, acting on things,
asking questions, you know,
sometimes it's literally
can we ask some questions?
For this particular job
that we're hiring for...
I noticed the job description says,
must have a four year college degree.
You know, can I ask about that?
What do you see as essential
and in the job description
around the four year college degree?
I mean, it's worth asking a question,
or I noticed that, you know, in meetings,
I noticed that people always sit
in this particular configuration.
I guess we don't sit in
meetings anymore, but like,
but you know what I mean?
Or I noticed that, you know,
we invite these people to Zoom
and we don't include
this level of employee.
I was wondering about that.
I wonder if we've ever tried
inviting the full staff
to the Zoom discussion.
Just asking questions begins the process.
So, we're not always in a position
where we feel like we can just make change
or even articulate the
change we'd like to see,
but we can almost always ask questions.
- And this gets to kind of my last thing
I wanted to talk to you
about was that, you know,
so far, we've been talking
about how we should strive
to be good ish people, you know,
but you're here as part of this event
where we're talking
about belonging at Yale.
And so I wanted you to riff a little bit
on how we can become kind
of good ish organizations
or good ish universities, right,
are all the strategies
that you just talked about,
for the individual people
watching this right now?
You know, how did those
apply in the context
of like Yale University say?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, that's actually, I
think, one of the coolest things
that I felt my own understanding emerge
in working on this book,
was I'm trained to think about individuals
like as a social psychologist.
But there was this realization that
individuals are part of
institutions and communities
and that what we are noticing, the butter,
we're not noticing that
in the fridge or the pens,
we're not noticing in the junk drawer,
that what we're not noticing
are the systems around us.
So when we start noticing more,
when we give ourselves
permission to notice more,
and then we do notice more,
we will start to those
systems will become visible.
So, if I was a member of your community,
I would just start to think about the ways
in which I might be benefiting
from certain systems.
And what are the ways in which
I could start nudging others
to notice that that noticing as well.
And the best way to do that, by the way,
I think earlier, you
mentioned the holier than thou
and I don't think I
addressed that directly.
The best way to do that,
is to make your own
learning visible to others.
And what that means is
this isn't about I know more than you,
this is about, I have been
trying to figure something out
and hey, like we're all
working on this big puzzle,
you're on that part, I'm on this part,
I think I got this corner figured out,
let me tell you how to do it.
And so making our own
learning visible to others
is really powerful.
So, I think in the community at Yale,
there's a tremendous opportunity to assume
that their system systemic problems,
let's just assume it's true.
I promise you it is.
There's no way Yale is
amazing places as it is
has somehow been immune
from 400 years of history
and, you know, widespread isms in society.
So the question isn't, do our
systems need to be addressed?
It's just how.
- And then I think another
thing you talk about
in your book a lot, which
I think is important
in the context of organizations, too,
is kind of passing the mic, right?
Like when you get the
opportunity really to listen
to people from different backgrounds
and hear what their
lived experience is like.
- Yeah, that's really powerful.
And that's another way in
which we cookie seekers,
is we talk more than we listen.
There's a great little acronym
that Michael Bungay Stanier
came up with called...
It was in a completely different context.
It was context of coaching, but
he calls it the weight rule.
The why am I talking? Cool.
I found that really
useful in every context,
not just these contexts,
like the kinds of study
but in all contexts, and
why am I talking rule.
But particularly, when we cookie seek,
we're usually talking,
there's almost always words
coming out of our mouth.
- Yeah, and then I think
that sort of builds up
to like, another question,
which is this idea that,
you know, if you're from a majority group,
you're often benefiting from
these structures, right?
Like when we think about
the structural changes
that will make a Yale evening things out
means that there's gonna be some people
who are kind of having the tailwinds
kind of go down a little bit.
But there's this worry that
that might mean, you know,
the headwinds are gonna
go down a little bit, too.
And so what advice do you have
for people who kind of want to
make these systemic changes,
when they realize they might be kind of
facing the possibility that
some people perceive, you know,
things getting more just
as things getting unfair,
you know, for the, like,
the non marginalized folks
who kind of feel like,
well, you know, why would I,
as a white man have to talk less?
Or why would I, as a straight
person have to, you know,
think differently?
Or why would I as able bodied
person have to worry about,
you know, text on my screen
or something like that,
like, what advice do you get
when you kind of get that
criticism brought to you?
- Yeah, well, I have
some unpublished data.
So it's a paper we're still working on.
But we've got some data that suggests that
would help us stay engaged
or get more engaged
in those moments, is connecting
it to a bigger picture.
And this is very
consistent also with like,
sort of classic work in psychology
around affirming the self
and creating affirmations.
I don't mean like affirmations,
like things you stand in
the mirror and look at,
and shave yourself,
but just in the jargon of our field,
sort of reflecting on your own values
is one form of affirmation.
And what research shows
is that when you connect those moments
that you're experiencing those
that are specifically around you,
and your interests and your ego,
if you can connect it to a bigger picture,
that seems to create
greater resilience for us,
around our self image, around our ego.
It is true in any one given moment,
there might be a fixed pie, right?
In any one given moment,
there might be, you know,
one job or one, whatever.
But in the grand scheme of things,
we tend to underestimate
how much the pie can grow.
In negotiations research,
they see this all the time,
they call it the mythical fixed pie,
that we think my loss is
your gain and vice versa.
When in fact, there's actually
many more opportunities
for multiple people,
myself and others to gain
than I realize.
If I'm to be a little more
kind of, pushy on this,
I would say, I don't even
think we have the option
to wait anymore.
And I think that moment came and went,
where you can sort of choose to opt out
of these conversations.
I think we're now in the
midst of dramatic change,
long overdue, and it's time as a builder
to sort of figure out
what your role is gonna be
in advancing that change,
as opposed to worrying about
if the change should happen,
or if the change will benefit me.
The change is a lot better
chance of benefiting you,
if you're part of it, than
if you're resisting it.
And so I think that's true,
no matter how you look at it
in terms of cultural norms,
in terms of demographics in this country,
I think in terms of sort of what skills
are being valued by employers,
and admissions officers,
no matter how you look at it,
one is better off taking the stance of
I'm going to be building
this change as part of it,
that as opposed to questioning
it or resisting it.
- And then my final
question for you tonight,
kind of talks a little
bit about where we are
in 2020, right now, where,
you know, these conversations
are more needed than ever,
more important than ever,
but they can also be a
little bit exhausting.
And so this is kind of ending
with a little bit of a personal question.
You are, you know, central
in this fight for justice,
central in this fight, referring
to kind of getting people
to think about being
goodish people, and so on.
But that fight can be kind
of exhausting sometimes.
And I think, you know, on
behalf of all of our activists
is a number another set of questions
that we got a lot of, it's like,
how do you kind of
protect your mental health
in the face of this stuff?
You know, how do you
protect your mental health
in the face of like, you
know, turning on the heat,
when people really seem
like they're not listening?
Or you think your giving light
and your not doing the light version
and getting a lot of pushback.
Like, how do you protect yourself
in the face of all this stuff?
- Yeah, it really is exhausting.
And it is important,
because we want people in it
for the long haul.
I wrote back in June, you know,
maybe three weeks after
George Floyd was murdered,
I decided to start this newsletter
that you refer to
earlier, Dear Good People.
And it was exactly for that reason,
it was that I was seeing folks
who were already exhausted,
now really exhausted,
and then other people sort
of joining the conversation
or trying to deepen their investment.
And I was worried about
by July, August, September, October,
where was everyone gonna be?
We're exhausted people
gonna be burned out?
And where newer people
going to have lost interest or confidence?
So, I wrote this piece
called the 10% More Rule,
and it's on my website,
dollychugh.com/newsletter,
but I'll just summarize it.
Basically, I think what we
all wanna do is 10% more,
if you're new to this conversation,
or new to this understanding,
then 10% more means
be 10% more mortified.
Like, don't look away, stay engaged.
That means we need you to
keep reading and watching
and listening and learning.
If you've been in this
conversation, you know,
you've hashtagged, you've
donated, you volunteered,
that kind of thing,
but, you know, if this
was a basketball game,
you were spending more time
on the bench then in the game,
taking hard fouls,
now it's time to be 10% more terrified.
That means, get in the game,
take a hard fought foul,
take a risk, essentially,
start Saying things at work,
start asking questions,
start reaching out,
start spending your comfort.
And then finally to the group,
you just refer to those
who've been on the frontlines
fighting so hard, a great
detriment to themselves at times,
they're in every way physical,
emotional, financial,
the 10% more refers to 10% more,
and these, I'm gonna do
air quotes, "satisfied."
And by that, I mean,
not satisfied with the
state of affairs at all.
But satisfied that you
can come out of the game,
you don't have to play every minute,
you can let everyone else
get in the game a little bit,
learning about the game
and playing the game,
you can step out and catch your breath
10% more than you have
been, and then come back in.
And I think that the key is that
if we're going to be sustainable in this,
one of the metaphors I share in the book
that someone I interviewed
offered me is a flock of birds.
Apparently, when you see
v formations of birds
flying about this time of year,
that the lead bird, the one
that's fighting those headwinds,
is rotating, it isn't
always the same bird,
which I did not know.
But it's for this exact reason
that if the lead bird was
gonna stay the lead bird
all the way to their final destination,
they literally aren't going to make it
to the final destination.
So let's rotate out.
So, I would say 10% more,
if you're on the front lines
means 10% less, essentially.
Not forever, just catching your breath.
- I think this is a
fantastic place to end,
because honestly,
I think if we really wanna
achieve belonging at Yale,
if literally all the 100s and
100s of people on this call
did 10% more at Yale, of
working to be a goodish person
and fighting so that everyone at Yale
feels like they belong,
I feel like we'd make a lot of progress
towards making this
institution a better place.
But I wanted to end by
thanking Dolly so deeply,
I hope you can all see now,
why she's so fantastic.
And her work is so fantastic.
Again, just to give her a couple plugs,
you should check out her book,
which I think she'll hold up right now
if she's sitting right near it.
Her book, "The Person You Mean to Be:
How Good People Fight Bias."
It's fantastic and really worth the read.
You can also even if you
need more bite sized chunks,
check out her newsletter
which she mentioned,
Dear Good People, which you can check out
@dollychugh.com/newsletter.
Thank you everyone for joining today
and for joining the fight
to get Yale to be a place
where everyone belongs.
I hope I will see you at the
next anti-racism webinar,
stay tuned to Yale news where
you'll hear more about that.
Ibram X. Kendi will also be fantastic.
And thank you to all the organizers
for putting this together.
Really appreciate having
you here today. Thanks.